[Musica]
la vita è un film e io sono la
protagonista
però sono anche l'autrice la
sceneggiatrice l'antagonista
il mio ego centrismo mi impone di
pensare che io sia stata la causa di
tutti i colpi di scena che la mia vita
il mio film mi ha riservato fino adesso
e di tutti quelli che mi riserverà in
futuro
ma lasciate che io vi permetta di
conoscerla un pochino questa persona che
oggi questo film e lo presenta vi dico
da subito che non ho come obiettivo
quello di far vene innamorare non mi
interessa che voi alla fine vogliate poi
comprare il biglietto per me sarà già un
grandissimo traguardo farvi incuriosire
del trailer
oggi io questo film lo sento ricco lo
sento pieno non è ancora pronto per il
debutto sul grande schermo però è
completo nella sua incompletezza è
completo però facciamo
tanti passi indietro
il mio film la mia vita
inizia 26 anni fa
e inizia nei peggiori dei modi perché
stava finendo con prima di cominciare
proprio la l'infermiere andando da mio
padre ha detto no sua figlia non ce la
fa rabbia io oggi sono qui dopo 26 anni
sono nata biondissima e sono pronte per
raccontarvi cosa è successo in questi 26
anni
sappiate che come tutti i film se mai
dovesse decidere di andarla a vedere vi
ritroverete a
avere due tempi il primo tempo sarà
quello caratterizzato dalla scuola dalla
danza dagli amichetti dalla danza
dalla danza
quindi vedrete scarpette rosa ovunque
lacrime per una coreografia sbagliata
ansia per il saggio del giorno dopo poi
l'ansia rimasta peraltro però è rimasta
vedrete il teatro
vedrete tutti gli inchini che ho
lasciato su quei palchi che forse oggi
mi hanno permesso di essere un po meno
fifona qui di fronte a voi vedrete tutti
i posti in cui sono stato a raccontare
storie i nomi e tutte le maschere che ho
indossato
e poi vedrete quelle che io chiamo le
mie costanti gli amori che ho sempre
avuto che penso rimarranno per sempre la
mia famiglia mia madre mio padre la mia
sorellina che giuro ha 9 anni meno di me
che quando l'ho presa in braccio la
prima volta 18 anni fa ho capito che
avrei potuto proteggere qualcuno e avrei
potuto amare qualcuno
e poi vedrete anche cose tipo i tagli di
capelli perché voglio cambiare la vita
quando la vita andava ancora così bene
però i segni di ribellione penso che
avremmo avuti tutti
quello che penso che però vi rimarrà più
impressa sarà il secondo tempo di questo
film perché lì ci sarà la crescita che
saranno le cazzate le prime delusioni
date e ricevute le prime dediche
pensate che la prima canzone che mi è
stata dedicata in vita mia
era di alessandra amoroso e diceva è
vero che vuoi restare
e né io e né quella persona siamo
restati l'una per l'altra
l'unica l'unica costante che vedrete
dall'inizio alla fine sarà l'amore per
la scrittura
il mio più grande modo per sfogarmi la
mia più grande passione
all'inizio sarà un diario segreto poi
dei pensieri stropicciati oggi è un
libro
oggi sono i miei tatuaggi
però nel secondo tempo
vedrete la protagonista
cioè io
in un modo che probabilmente vi farà
dire a
perché io sono stata anche una ragazza
immatura una ragazza superficiale una
ragazza che non pesava le parole non
pesava i gesti che faceva
poi sono stata anche questo
sono stata una ragazza di 40 kg una
ragazza che si nutriva di ansia da
attacchi di panico che non andava a fare
la spesa senza la mamma perché pensava
che sarebbe morta da sola è stata una
ragazza che a un certo punto ha smesso
di mangiare perché perché aveva paura di
strozzarsi perché aveva paura di morire
perché aveva paura di ingrassare di non
piacersi o di non piacere agli altri
sono stata una ragazza che per anni si è
fatta le foto e poi le cancellava le
tagliava perché solo nelle foto riusciva
a vedere che qualcosa effettivamente non
andava e sono stata una ragazza che per
anni non ha creduto neanche al suo
specchio ma ha creduto solo alla sua
testa
però io tutto questo tutto questo lo
custodito perché mi ha permesso di
arricchirlo questo film ho fatto la cosa
più bella sbaglio o sbagliato sbagliato
non parlo di questo non parlo di questo
parlo dell'immaturità
questa è stata una parte del percorso
che ho superato grazie al mio primo
colpo di scena
il mio primo colpo di scena
si chiama erika
ricci castani occhi scuri ma sinceri
l'anima tormentata dal futuro un po
incerto erica è stato l'incastro
perfetto del mio puzzle un puzzle che
fino a quel momento io avevo
completamente sbagliato a comporre
perché era una regista impreparata e
quindi ho confuso e confuso i pezzi
mille volte lei più piccola di me mi ha
paradossalmente insegnato a vivere forse
anch'io l'ho fatto con lei ma la cosa
veramente importante è che lei l'abbia
fatto con me del mio momento di gr di
immaturità
lei mi ha abitato la testa sulle spalle
mi ha insegnato
il peso delle parole
lei è stata la mia co protagonista la
mia lady che poi ho tatuato anche sul
petto e così è nata una grandissima
storia d'amore una grandissima storia
d'amore che oggi mi ha permesso anche di
essere qui più matura con 10 chili in
più
che però non ha avuto una vita facile
fin da subito certo una storia d'amore
che quando la guardi da una parte sei
felice dall'altra parte un po ti incazzi
perché quando guardi film d'amore dice a
me non mi capitava così che la vorresti
vivere una cosa così intensa io grazie a
lei non rimpiango il film d'amore
però purtroppo la mia non è una favola
per bambini e attenzione perché adesso
arriva il secondo colpo di scena quello
che vi fa crollare tutto l'entusiasmo se
ne avete avuto ho captato fino a questo
momento
ma non mostrate queste cose perché siete
ridicoli
lesbiche schifose al rogo
voi non siete genitore 1 o genitore 2
voi siete un errore della natura
schifose no non fate schifo di più se
tutti fanno come voi il mondo finirà
fate schifo
ora mi segue morite bruciato in un lager
lesbiche del cazzo morite bruciate
lesbiche di merda purificatevi
martina tamaro fanno bene i bulli degli
omosessuali che vi rompono la faccia
dovevi essere mia figlia vedere cosa ti
facevo svergognate
ma lo capite che se devo il problema non
siamo noi noi siamo normali quelli
malati e malati e siete voi quindi
dovete rispettarci poi a casa potete
fare anche le vostre schifezze se foste
nate nel medio oriente avreste avuto la
pena giusta a sassate
tutte ste lesbiche di merda bruciate nel
forno malati bruciate ciao perle dei
miei [ __ ] [ __ ] lesbiche stronze
bruciate andate a morire nei forni
dovrebbe essere uccisa anzi sterminata
morite al rogo che del cazzo bruciate
ammazzatevi morte male [ __ ]
ma è valutato il suicidio morì tester
minate da cancro dolorosamente
brutalmente troglodite cancerogeni spero
moriate soffrendo esageratamente luride
bastarde
morese di tubercolosi violenta e brutale
mentre soffrite spero moriate soffrendo
molto bastard e
pregherò la vostra morte
lgbt merda bruciate morite
ok
e mi sono detta e loro chi sono
antagonisti
protagonisti
chi sono perché io sono sicura di non
averli inseriti nella sceneggiatura
quando scritto il film anzi non ho
neanche aperto i casting per queste
persone è pure me li ritrovo perché
forse non sono sempre stata io
all'artificio del mio destino
e quindi abbiamo conosciuto questo
mostro che l'omofobia è l'uomo fobia non
è solo quando ti picchiano per strada
via anche quando ti chiedono di non dire
in giro che se con una ragazza perché si
vergognano e quando ti guardano male
perché tiene la mano alla tua ragazza in
pubblico e quando trattano la tua
relazione come se fosse un influenza con
frasi del tipo passerà però non è
un'influenza ovviamente non passerà
e poi l'uomo fobia ovviamente sono
questi i commenti così io ed erika noi
abbiamo ricevute più di 3.000
letteralmente e se pensate che io oggi
sia qui per dirvi che non mi hanno fatto
niente o che non mi hanno distrutta
psicologicamente siete fuori strada
però in quella parte del film in cui la
protagonista si ritrova sulla crisi
sull'orlo di una crisi dove pensa che
vorrebbe mollare tutto anzi no pensa che
non avrebbe neanche mai voluto
cominciarlo questo film che arriva
l'idea
quella di trasformare una cosa cosi
brutta e cattiva in una cosa
terribilmente bella ho creato un profilo
una pagina social le perle degli omofobi
dove ho fatto questo ho mostrato gli
insulti da una parte l'amore con erika
dall'altra
ho ricevuto tanti complimenti per questa
pagina che poi ha avuto un seguito
assurdo perché perché ho solo mostrato
l'amore ho solo ricordato che non c'è
nulla di sbagliato di ambiguo di diverso
in una relazione tra due donne oltre a
due uomini
perché sono sicura di essere solo la
briciola di un pane pieno di persone
stanche a case a causa della
discriminazione di qualsiasi tipo
e così abbiamo trasformato qualcosa di
avvilente in qualcosa di propositivo
speciale nuovo è quello che vorrei che
facesse tutti voi
e chiaro che io non parlo solo di
omofobia perché non potrà mai e
riguardare voi tutti ovviamente però
sono certo è che ciascuno di voi abbia
dentro di sé un altro problemino e ci
stia pensando proprio in questo momento
continuate a pensarci è normale che voi
riusciate a questa e se sì ma tu cosa ne
sai mica lo conosci ma è vero io non lo
conosco però voi sì voi sapete i suoi
punti deboli sapete qual è il punto
debole dell'omofobia è proprio l'amore
ecco perché ne abbiamo reagito con
quello trovate il punto debole del
vostro problema e poi risolvete lo così
trasformandola semplicemente in una cosa
bella arrivate in quella parte del film
sedetevi davanti a un tavolino prendete
il copione poi prendete la matita quella
call gommino dietro e poi scrivete
cancellate scrivete cancellate scrivete
e fate in modo che questo film mi lasci
sempre il sorriso sulle labbra
anzi no fate in modo di essere fieri di
essere stati protagonisti di
un'avventura del genere
e sarà questo il vostro finale con i
fiocchi quello di aver preso una cosa
che avrebbe potuto e voluto distruggervi
averla fatta diventare paradossalmente
il vostro punto di forza il mio film
oggi non è finito
ed è anche per questo che voi non potete
ancora andarlo a vedere è in corso
ho pensato mille volte al testo che
avrei scritto per poi raccontarvelo qui
è la verità è che io il testo finale non
l'ho mai scritto perché solo ieri in up
in hotel
ho capito che non avrei mai potuto
raccontarvi il mio film bene e non avrei
mai potuto raccontarvi le scene che
nella mia testa sono così nitide ed
importanti non avrei mai potuto farvi
arrivare il 100 per cento di quello che
ho nel cuore ed è lì che ho capito ho
capito che i nostri figli dobbiamo
impostarli su noi stessi dobbiamo farli
arrivare a noi dobbiamo viverli per far
piacere a noi e non per farle piacere
agli altri
anche perché non avrei saputo farmi
piacere l'arancione le patatine fritte e
il catch up sulla posta ma comunque
come diceva l'insieme film oggi al ricco
e pieno di personaggi meravigliosi e mia
famiglia erika ma non solo melissa
debora daniele giusy andrea federica a
jacopo federico martina sarà irene
veronica sono tutti personaggi che lo
riempono e mi riempiono e non lo so se
sarà un successo al botteghino ma sono
sicura che per me sarà un successo
veramente nel cuore
una volta ho scritto un pensiero
stropicciato che diceva una scatola non
è piena quando straborda ma quando
nonostante lo spazio disponibile non
riesce più ad accogliere nulla
ecco oggi io quel pensiero stropicciato
grazie anche a loro lo riesco a capire
veramente oggi finalmente ha un senso
vi chiedo scusa perché mi rendo conto di
avervi raccontato tutto questo senza
nemmeno averlo fatto di pop corn
però spero che vi farà almeno un po
piacere sapere che da oggi anche voi
sarete delle piacevolissime comparse di
questa mia eterna pellicola
[Applauso]